So if you fast forward a few years, there're been a lot of new ideas
that have come into CUDA between the time you launched 5 or 6 years ago and today.
So what are maybe the 2 or 3 coolest ideas that you think have come in since the time you launched?
&gt;&gt; Well certainly we've added a lot of support for managing concurrency.
There's no shortage of parallelism in these codes if people want to move to the GPU.
So we've added better support for concurrency, for streams.
We've even moved some of that from what started out in software support--
actually is now baked into the hardware with the Kepler and the hyper queue.
Those are pieces of silk and they're actually inspired by
some of the stuff we were doing in software, originally with CUDA 2.0.
Other stuff we've been doing is integrating closer with the memory hierarchy.
In CUDA 4.0 we did the UVA work, which is unifying the virtual address base
of the entire machine such that--this was work we did
so tightly integrating with the operating system
such that a bi-pointer value,
the system can know if memory is living on the CPU or living on the GPU.
So there's no separate memory spaces anymore.
You can simply dereference a pointer, it goes to the right machine--
a right CPU or GPU or your peer's GPU.
That made multi-GPU programming way easier
than we had before CUDA 4.0.
&gt;&gt; Yeah, I mean as a professor, I think usually what I say is
the most common error is accessing memory on the wrong side of the machine. >> Yeah.
&gt;&gt; You think you're dereferencing a GPU pointer, and it's really on the CPU.
That's certainly very helpful in going out and doing those.